welcome back Greg Abbott wants drug
lords to pay while Matt get Gates says
bombs away
Texas governor Craig Abbott has issued
an executive order on Mexican drug
cartels that designates them as
terrorist organizations a second
executive order designated beta O'Rourke
as a weenie
but that was just for fun Abbott also
sent a letter to President Biden
requesting Federal terrorist
classifications for the cartels noted
Abbott more Americans died from fentanyl
poisoning in the past year than all
Terror attacks across the globe in the
past 100 years well the president
responded by nodding off into a bowl of
rocky road
that tastes good so as poisoning surge
have we finally had enough Florida
Congressman Matt Gates says we should
bomb the [ __ ] out of cartels
I added the F part
thank you
swear words off Fox News can be so
pissed off at me here's Gates it irks me
every time I hear someone talk about
fentanyl overdoses because no one
overdoses on fentanyl because I don't
think anybody really sets out to like
score some fentanyl for a good time I
get why it's hard to keep cocaine from
coming into the country people in the
United States like using cocaine they
seek it out they pay high dollar amounts
for it and so that would be something
hard to stop I know who I'm calling next
time I'm in Miami
just kidding it's still Gloria Estefan
she is the best we have the best talks
but it's clever you never hear about
fentanyl from a customer preference
point of view sounds like someone's been
reading my diary
please continue Matt but since people
don't set out to use fentanyl since it's
something we don't want in our country
we should be totally capable of stopping
it and the only reason we aren't is
because we purposefully allow our border
to degrade another great point but if it
were easy to keep something evil from
crossing our borders we would have never
heard of Justin Bieber
foreign
so here's the big idea
of lives
in every community in our country and we
seemingly like clutch our Pearls at the
suggestion that we might think about
dropping off a few tomahawk missiles in
the Sinaloa mountains where we know that
that fentanyl is being manufactured
great idea but now we just have to get
our missiles back from Ukraine
at least we know where Jesse's hair went
right
the administration will take out the
cartels the same way they took out the
Taliban by giving them tons of weapons
and hope they shoot themselves
in part
real victims are people who like drugs
but you can only buy them on the street
and you could die because fentanyl's in
all of it so he was like speaking at it
from the customer's POV which was kind
of nice yeah well you just gotta you
just have to legalize all drugs I mean
talking about making them a terror a
terrorist organization the cartels so
all these problems are caused by the
drug war and they're like we know what
we're going to do we're going to amp up
the drug War uh the more you go after
Smugglers the more popular fentanyl
becomes because it's more potent and
it's easier to smuggle and also it's
cheaper to produce than heroin is and
obviously all of this is due to the fact
that when they crack down on
prescription opiates more people started
dying because they were going to the
black market and it's also this horrible
impact on chronic pain patients who
can't get the medication that they need
to live a normal life uh I know that a
lot of people think it sounds crazy but
look at how it's been going the way
they've been doing it so maybe they
should try something else I agree you
know tires I also agree with blowing
them to Smithereens I don't like if it's
a terror if they're if they are a
terrorist if they're designated as a
terrorist group we can find out where
these cartels are well if you try an
actual War yeah on drugs that might be
effective not a fake one
um
if you did blow these cartels to
Smithereens they would have also have a
hard time tracking trafficking people
they would have a hard time taking girls
and putting them into the sex uh trade
industry so but you would uh you would
have to then lock down the Border
because you wouldn't they wouldn't be
able to run in so you'd have to
reinforce aboard our troops would have
to be at the border we'd have to scan
people coming in and flying in so yeah
it would be just for the just for the
Optics just the idea sometimes just
seeing in the United States tanks
sitting at the border like you know what
maybe we're not going to try to run
smuggling in this week so and you would
see it a drop in fentanyl because the
only thing about Gates is like I just
feel like the only thing was missing was
him saying for me personally because he
was literally talking about himself I
mean
I can remember that like me and my
brother would want to have a friend
spend the night yeah your kids but we
didn't want to make it like it was I had
to go speak for both of us right to ask
my mom right and I would be like so I've
heard people would prefer if our friends
stayed over here tonight not me I mean I
don't you know I'm with you Mom I'm
whatever you want but just for the
neighborhood and overhaul sense of
everyone who wants our friend to spend
the night tonight I think it'd be really
cool if they could have him over but not
me personally because I don't I think he
spoke for I think he spoke for more than
two I think he spent for him his crew
and his and his favorite drug dealer
[Laughter]
Dagan is it possible to strike a deal
with the cartels I mean even they got to
see this is a terrible business you
don't want to kill your customers off
right I mean you don't because they're
hard to replace well
they are yeah that's what I it doesn't
make any sense about this at all but it
is coming from China so you gotta yeah
yeah
um Bay Aina Che yes
yes
um
that was Pig Latin for people under the
age of 50. it took me a while I haven't
heard Pig Latin in so long
um Latin people feel about that
definitely terrorist organization though
Greg yes but
big butt yeah the bar is very low for me
in terms of who I think or terrorists
men who uh here we go clear their
throats and spit in public anybody with
an air horn in their car like a train
horn yeah incredibly loud are there a
lot of those yes
I mean that I think you're toxic I think
you're talking about it's kind of like
the gates thing I can't Bliss you know
this people who eat the grapes in the
produce section just stand there and eat
the grapes yeah terrorists
or anyone who thinks that Rascal Flatts
is a great man I love them
all right uh I do enjoy a good grape I
don't feel like I should have to buy the
whole bushel for just
[Music]
um
I'm that way with six packs of beer yeah
hey me is there I I know probably know
the answer to this question
um in Alaska they actually want more
fence at all because everybody wants to
end their miserable lives
I thought you made the greatest Point
ever about they're killing their
customers yeah I mean it works for
McDonald's
but um
completely with cat that I think
legalization if for nothing else you
know what's in everything exactly at the
very least you know what's in there and
like because I had even before it would
I use marijuana sometimes I'm not
embarrassed to say and before it was
recreationally allowed I had a medical
card and before people make fun like I
had like a legitimate like medical like
Wednesdays make me sad yeah and so
that's why
I had to take did you hear that they're
going to have I think they're called
like narcon vending machines right so
the two like like for the so people
don't like have Fentanyl and their stuff
and my problem is I don't like the idea
of a vending machine I feel like what if
your friends oding and then it's just
like stuck in the window yeah yes or you
or you only have one dollar and they
also have Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
yeah that's a tough choice that is a
tough choice and just lastly why do they
keep putting marijuana in delicious
delicious things I'm a guy that likes
food and they're like hey eat a corner
of this brownie no why don't you put it
in a carrot or something yeah quit
putting wheat in delicious foods yeah
why putting in stock put in stuff I
don't like to eat yes brussels sprouts
then I'll eat the Brussels sprouts that
is the best idea of the night
I never thought of that the Healthy High
the Healthy High the Healthy High you
just you just came up with a business
finally you can make some money Jamie
this is a business you just copyright
because these we're taped you go home
copyright Healthy High healthyhigh.com
Healthy High
it's such a great idea that is a really
good idea it's a great idea okay you
have to think about it broccoli that
that you eat there you go I'm so glad so
free grapes with weed eating it up next
ashes to ashes dust to dust will human
mulch be a boom or bust that is amazing